as america struggles with covid rising
crime and riots it's nice that the
teachers unions are helping out i kid
and their demands for reopening schools
the united teachers of la a union for
public school teachers has included
surprise defunding the police and
a shutdown of publicly funded privately
operated
charter schools now these go beyond what
normal unions demand
worse they use this crisis to preserve
their power by destroying those who
won't conform
by trying to shut down charter schools
they're demanding the elimination of any
competition
and depriving desperate poor families
of an education that might change their
kids lives
this speaks to the real truth of a big
american problem it's not systemic
racism
it's our systemically corrupt education
system it's the teachers unions
led by leftists whose only goal is to
cancel competition
that might reveal their incompetence and
so at the start of life poor students
are placed in a system
where no matter no matter how many
billions of tax dollars are shoveled
into it it just gets worse
the students don't stand a chance and
the unions prefer it that way
yet charter schools produced better
educated kids with a far better head
started life
you think that would be embraced but the
price of union success
is student failure once we see the
results of charter schools we realize
the cause of all our inequalities
isn't racism it's the scandalous lack of
choices
left for poor blacks poor whites poor
everyone
victimized by urban liberals so these
kids begin their lives in a hole
a hole that isn't a grave but might as
well be one at least for their futures
uh dana how can a union
make these demands i mean is this just
basically symbolic crap
well i think partly it's that the unions
are not serving the teachers or the
students well
and this happens often when you have a
union that wants to get involved in
other political matters like defunding
the police
um and this is really probably not the
time to be
doing an exercise in overreach because
um
you've had people who have had to
rethink everything
maybe their job maybe where they live um
maybe
you know how they live and how they
educate their kids
many school districts including i
believe down in uh miami that they're
pushing school back they're starting
later they're going to start online and
then they're going to try to figure out
a way to get into classrooms
i think people generally want their kids
back in school but they are really
concerned about safety
however one of the things that this is
also doing is make people think about
how they educate their kids and
necessity is the mother of invention
and you have the opportunity now to say
wait
why do i have to do it this way maybe i
could try it a different way
and you start to see the possibility of
either homeschooling or little pods
or people getting together now that
might leave behind though and this very
real concern
the lower income students that you were
talking about
so that has to be a consideration but i
think that this pandemic
is going to forever change the way that
some
parents decide to teach their kids at
home
juan what could be their legitimate
defense of wanting to
defund uh charter schools
a charter school has worked and you just
say that i agree with you uh
you know i say that generally obviously
there's some charter schools that don't
work but i think in
general it's innovation and it it forces
the option to be made available to
parents to say i like this school or i
don't like this school and it does away
a lot
with a lot of the kind of zip code
segregation you know
where kids in better neighborhoods get
better schools because they get
more supplemental funding more parent
parental support
you know just picking up on what dana
was saying one of the issues has to be
that if you have innovation and the like
do poor kids
uh you know oftentimes i say this with a
sad heart kids
coming from single parent families where
the mom may be an essential worker
low-income worker and not able to
provide that kind of personal
interaction with the kid during the day
does that child therefore get left
behind that would have been me and i
think that
you know obviously you can imagine how i
feel and i'm a big school choice
proponent
just one last thought though greg on the
opening of schools i just want to make
it clear that even
people like the governor of new jersey
phil murphy a democrat bill gates
nobody's a hard-line you know
conservative but
these people everybody wants schools
open it's just a matter
of doing it safely parents are hardwired
to protect their children
teachers obviously have a stake in this
and i think we have to just work at it
but we can we'll find a way
speaking of which i think we have tape
of bill gates and a couple of governors
saying the very that
what juan just said if we want to play
that i'm a big believer that for young
children
uh the benefits in almost every location
uh particularly if you can protect the
teachers well the benefits outweigh the
costs as you get up to age like 13 and
higher
then you'll have to look at your locale
to decide what you'll do with
high schools and if they're not in then
you have to put massive effort
into trying to get there to be continued
learning online
the science is clear our kids need to be
in school
for us our kids are going back to school
on time we've had great
definitely they will definitely be in
the classroom
every education expert we've spoken to
over the past few months
has confirmed that in-person education
is critical we must try to include at
least some aspect of in-person education
for our children this fall
uh katie feel free to either discuss
that or the unions your pick
well that's the scientific uh path that
everybody should be following when it
comes to kids being in schools but on
the union side it is just
absolutely despicable that they're
putting this laundry list of demands
into
the futures of america's kids when they
claim that they actually
you know care about them and pretend to
care about them and it's the reason why
a lot of teachers around the country
have actually sued their governments
which have forced them into these unions
because they don't want to be part
of a political party and pay dues to
those unions when they don't have the
best interest
of the kids in mind in terms of getting
rid of the charter schools they want to
do that because
charter schools present them with
competition and force them to do better
and they don't want to do better they
just want to be paid for not doing their
jobs and they want to hold kids hostage
for generations to come if this keeps
going on
jesse uh the president of the american
federation
teachers federation is going to be on
the daily briefing tomorrow with dana
perino to discuss this
i assume you will be tuning in and
watching it as always
also greg did you dress like a middle
school math teacher just to do this
monologue
yeah it's like honestly this is a new
shirt my
middle finger did you have sweat stains
here too
chalk in your hands my god you also
dressed like
and i'm very bitter the glasses and the
sweater enough about you greg
this was a social justice shakedown did
you have any idea the teachers union was
this liberal i mean
who wrote the demands omar this is
fanatical stuff here no wonder the kids
can riot
better than they can read i'm terrified
of the teachers union i think they're
the most hardcore union out there
but i can't say anything mean about them
because i'll be attacked for going after
teachers
i just know that trump just sent him a
hundred billion i hope that winds up
in the right hands and not into some
pockets of some administrators
for fatter pensions and bonuses i hope
that goes to the right place
yeah it's such a good point if you may
if you say something about the unions
they accuse you of going after teachers
and then you're an evil evil person
which i am